Caption: hello Rob just asked if he wanted him to
Caption: introduce me and I said no so I'm gonna
Caption: introduce myself I'm Alice I'm a
Caption: software developer at ratify and today
Caption: I'm going to be talking to you all about
Caption: this idea of creative coding and
Caption: particularly in relationship to the
Caption: JavaScript canvas now to start off with
Caption: why do we care about this Who am I
Caption: what's going on so as I said before I'm
Caption: I'm Alice and I'm a developer but in my
Caption: spare time I'm also an artist and I do a
Caption: lot of creative visual work which is
Caption: usually in very traditional mediums like
Caption: paint not the computer paint that and
Caption: when I was growing up when I was a
Caption: teenager this was a bit problematic when
Caption: it came to school because I found that
Caption: in the syllabus it was really hard to do
Caption: an art class and a computer class at the
Caption: same time the syllabus was just not set
Caption: up for you to do those two courses it's
Caption: because they're like well you know
Caption: computer programming it's really it's in
Caption: the scientific half of the syllabus and
Caption: then there's art and that's a creative
Caption: you know the left brain side of things
Caption: and so the idea of someone wanting to do
Caption: both of those things at the same time in
Caption: our education system was viewed as it's
Caption: like a bit weird sorry I think my hairs
Caption: touching that a bit so I'm really keen
Caption: through my work and through other
Caption: avenues to really promote this idea that
Caption: those really aren't two different things
Caption: they actually can see it quite closely
Caption: together now I should clarify that I
Caption: think there are a lot of really useful
Caption: talks here today that I know I've picked
Caption: up some things and I'm like I'm gonna
Caption: take this back to my work next week and
Caption: start incorporating it it's gonna be
Caption: really useful and that kind of thing
Caption: that's this is not particularly useful
Caption: it's just kind of cool
Caption: I find it entertaining I don't know so
Caption: this is just going to be a basic
Caption: introduction to the JavaScript canvas
Caption: and some ways you can make some really
Caption: simple art visualizations using it these
Caption: aren't gonna be very advanced these are
Caption: just the basic tools that you might like
Caption: to use and then you can really take that
Caption: in any direct
Caption: so this is an example of a very very
Caption: simple canvas element with a very simple
Caption: illustration on it it's a cube it's not
Caption: very interesting all I've done here is
Caption: locate the canvas and draw a rectangle
Caption: on it so pretty much all we can do with
Caption: the canvas is we can draw squares on it
Caption: we can draw circles on it we can draw
Caption: lines and we can make those things
Caption: different colors I think one of the
Caption: reasons I enjoy this medium so much is
Caption: because there's not really a complicated
Caption: framework to interact with it you can
Caption: draw points on a screen and you can put
Caption: those points where you want to put them
Caption: there's not really anything more to it
Caption: than that
Caption: so I think probably the first
Caption: interesting thing you do with this kind
Caption: of frame is to introduce animation to it
Caption: so there are probably two components to
Caption: this that I should explain firstly we're
Caption: using time here to position something on
Caption: the screen and secondly we're requesting
Caption: a frame from your browser and saying hey
Caption: you know give me a frame you notice that
Caption: I could write this function within a
Caption: loop and say 60 times a second can you
Caption: please supply a frame but I think it's
Caption: better to request the foam and then the
Caption: browser can actually you know if you're
Caption: like hey chrome give me some frames and
Caption: Chrome's like no I have 500 tabs open I
Caption: don't have any power to do that it's
Caption: fine like so you'll notice if you if you
Caption: put that in a loop that runs at a set
Caption: period of time you can kind of have some
Caption: really bad performance issues with your
Caption: browser which is probably not super
Caption: respectful of your users who might be
Caption: viewing your animation it might be a bit
Caption: problematic for them the other problem
Caption: with this initial animation is um so I
Caption: animated a cube and I haven't really I
Caption: don't know where it's gone it's like
Caption: over there cuz that's not bounded by
Caption: anything so it's pretty easy to add some
Caption: simple constraints so that that would
Caption: keep within the confines of the canvas
Caption: that you're drawing on so here it's just
Caption: modded by the width of the canvas which
Caption: produces a pretty boring animation of a
Caption: cube rotating I mean speeding through
Caption: space it's not particularly interesting
Caption: but through chucking and some other
Caption: elements so here I've just introduced a
Caption: simple sine wave to figure out where it
Caption: sits on the y-axis
Caption: we can make that movement feel a lot
Caption: more natural and a bit more engaging to
Caption: the eye what I think is interesting
Caption: about working with these kinds of
Caption: formulas is that you can kind of create
Caption: a something of them I would say a
Caption: personality maybe that's just me but
Caption: there's something about the way that's
Caption: certain like particularly like I find
Caption: sine and cosine waves move it's very
Caption: pleasing to the eye on it and it's very
Caption: engaging in a way that just a linear
Caption: movement back and forward is not now at
Caption: the side of my talk I promise that this
Caption: would not be interesting or financially
Caption: useful in any way I do think that
Caption: learning how to illustrate things in a
Caption: way that's engaging to a user or someone
Caption: watching it can actually be quite useful
Caption: when you are designing websites and
Caption: other applications I have a friend that
Caption: kind of refused to stop using facebook
Caption: Messenger because he really likes the
Caption: way when you click on the little like
Caption: you tap the little emoji in the bottom
Caption: right corner it expands and then it pops
Caption: and he's like yeah I just I just really
Caption: like doing that I don't want to I don't
Caption: want to leave so a simple little
Caption: animation like that can actually
Caption: generate value I don't know if this is
Caption: gonna generate any value for anyone it's
Caption: pretty not very interesting
Caption: so one thing I've been doing with these
Caption: simple illustrations is clearing the
Caption: canvas away every frame now that's not a
Caption: default behavior of the canvas and if
Caption: you don't do that you can start to
Caption: notice some weird things some weird
Caption: patterns emerging pretty quickly but
Caption: because I'm not styling this element in
Caption: any way it is not super engaging either
Caption: especially because pretty soon we're not
Caption: gonna be able to see anything cuz that's
Caption: gonna cover a whole canvas so luckily we
Caption: can use a fill style to programmatically
Caption: decide on our color in the same way that
Caption: we are programmatically deciding where
Caption: our element sits on the screen here you
Caption: can see you know when I mentioned before
Caption: that we're requesting the frame from the
Caption: browser so if that frame was being
Caption: supplied 60 times a million second we'd
Caption: see a much smoother line but those
Caption: little jitters are just due to my
Caption: browser probably having too many tabs
Caption: open now this is just a
Caption: element being drawn per frame in my mind
Caption: one of the really cool things about the
Caption: canvas element is that because it's so
Caption: cheap to draw rectangles particularly
Caption: rectangles you can draw other shapes as
Caption: well but a rectangle is quite a cheap
Caption: shape to draw you can actually draw up
Caption: to probably I would say about 60,000
Caption: different objects per second here I'm
Caption: not drawing that many it's only what
Caption: does that would be about 600 a second
Caption: and you can use that to create for lack
Caption: of a better word psychedelic vomit I
Caption: don't know like I say this isn't really
Caption: for anything it's just mucking around
Caption: with JavaScript and mucking around with
Caption: the canvas but to be honest I think the
Caption: idea of mucking around with coding is
Caption: quite valuable and often when I am
Caption: teaching programming to people for the
Caption: first time which I sometimes go out to
Caption: schools and I sometimes teach people who
Caption: otherwise wouldn't be interested in
Caption: programming about some basics I find
Caption: when you can introduce visual elements
Caption: and the concept of play into programming
Caption: it becomes a much more interesting
Caption: intriguing thing to learn so I promised
Caption: it wouldn't be at all useful but there
Caption: are two use cases that are outlined here
Caption: that might be good so the for the second
Caption: part of my talk I just wanted to show an
Caption: application that I have used this for
Caption: and I would like everyone to just cross
Caption: your fingers and toes for the live demo
Caption: gods because this may not work I have a
Caption: video if it doesn't but we'll see how we
Caption: go
Caption: I'm a little guy do did you do
Caption: luckily because I have no faith in the
Caption: live demo gods
Caption: I prepared a beautiful video of my
Caption: demonstration working and so if you
Caption: would also set then disbelief and
Caption: pretend that this is completely live so
Caption: this visualization here in a slightly
Caption: alternative universe where this just
Caption: connected perfectly to my projector is
Caption: actually taking a reading from this
Caption: headset which is a pretty boring reading
Caption: maybe it's actually come up since then
Caption: of no it hasn't but it's taken a pretty
Caption: uninteresting reading it's about eight
Caption: different levels of EEG data which often
Caption: referred to as like brainwave data and
Caption: I've used that to just project it onto
Caption: the canvas using the techniques that I
Caption: talked about before so there's simple
Caption: techniques of just positioning different
Caption: dots and shapes on a canvas and then
Caption: instead of time data instead what I've
Caption: done is projected my own brain data onto
Caption: a canvas to come up with some weird
Caption: looking thanks now a couple of caveats
Caption: about this I built this as a kind of
Caption: prototype to experiment with this kind
Caption: of technology
Caption: this particular headset aside from not
Caption: connecting to computers during live
Caption: demos is also not the quality of the
Caption: reading is not particularly what's the
Caption: word - ility so there are versions of
Caption: this technology that give you a precise
Caption: enough reading that you can apply
Caption: machine learning to it and move a cursor
Caption: out of screen for instance I actually
Caption: read a headline the other day that some
Caption: researchers have transcribed thought to
Caption: speech no like thought to text for the
Caption: first time using EEG headsets and
Caption: machine learning which I don't know
Caption: about you actually find that quite
Caption: terrifying because I kind of like my
Caption: thoughts for the most part being inside
Caption: my own mind rather than I don't know on
Caption: Facebook but I feel like because this
Caption: prototype is is much more artistic in
Caption: it's implementation it's not really
Caption: supposed to be a super scientific thing
Caption: that is perfectly reading my emotion
Caption: levels if I had a live demonstration up
Caption: and running I could show you when i if
Caption: i'm walking around the stage and if I'm
Caption: um if I'm gesturing then it will become
Caption: quite active and if I'm sort of sitting
Caption: there quietly it will become less active
Caption: and I kind of asked someone to like say
Caption: boo at me halfway through and like go
Caption: pretty crazy but you know down to like
Caption: the level that I guess where you could
Caption: actually use it to issue commands and
Caption: that kind of thing this tecnique like
Caption: this hardware is just not that precise
Caption: then again I did get this for free and
Caption: even if you bought it there only about
Caption: 90 bucks so I I I wouldn't make any
Caption: scientific claims or anything on that
Caption: kind of headset in fact on their website
Caption: they're explicitly like don't use this
Caption: for medical purposes so don't do that
Caption: so again if it's not for producing any
Caption: kind of scientific output if we're not
Caption: making anything useful with it then why
Caption: bother the main reason I built this was
Caption: to trick children into thinking that
Caption: computer science was cool and that they
Caption: might want to study it at uni with them
Caption: mixed results really it's really hard to
Caption: trick children to thinking anything is
Caption: cool but it's mainly to illustrate this
Caption: concept that I talked about at the start
Caption: of my speech which is that I don't
Caption: really think that you have scientific
Caption: mathematical things computer science on
Caption: one side and then artistic pursuits on
Caption: the other I think human beings are good
Caption: at lots of different things and
Caption: sometimes it's really fun to combine
Caption: those together and come up with some
Caption: interesting results I am because I go
Caption: out to schools and I talk about this
Caption: technology I asked the classroom of
Caption: people these of these young girls in
Caption: about 14 I said does anyone here do two
Caption: different things like I do I do
Caption: programming I do art does anyone do two
Caption: different things and I got some really
Caption: interesting results one girl was like I
Caption: play the violin and I do boxing and I
Caption: was like so what I'd really like to see
Caption: going forward is people bringing in some
Caption: more diverse skill sets into
Caption: computer programming because I think
Caption: there's some really interesting ways
Caption: that you can combine different skills
Caption: with with a programmatic or application
Caption: it doesn't always result in something
Caption: that's necessarily going to earn money
Caption: but sometimes it's just cool and I think
Caption: that's kind of fun maybe I think I only
Caption: ran for about 15 minutes so if anyone
Caption: has any questions that would be lovely I
Caption: guess no so I work with the platform
Caption: that sort of helps educate children
Caption: about the climate change and its
Caption: difference there do you see things like
Caption: this is a way to get more young people
Caption: into coding and programming a software
Caption: development I try so many ways to get
Caption: children into coding what I found really
Caption: interesting when I when I go and talk to
Caption: kids and if you ask them about what what
Caption: are you thinking about technology and
Caption: what are you scared of and how do you
Caption: feel about stuff they're already
Caption: thinking really deeply about a lot of
Caption: questions they're thinking about climate
Caption: change and they're thinking about AI and
Caption: stuff like that I went to a school and I
Caption: was like oh what are you worried about
Caption: with technology and this little boy was
Caption: like what if I go to uni and I study
Caption: really hard but then when I finish a
Caption: robot does my job and I was like next
Caption: question please
Caption: and I know the kid was like so is robots
Caption: taking everyone's job is that gonna be
Caption: really good because he won't have to do
Caption: any work or will it be really bad
Caption: because no one will have jobs and I was
Caption: like yes that is what will happen so in
Caption: terms of climate change I definitely
Caption: hear kids like talking about these two
Caption: concepts I don't there are lots of
Caption: different ways to get young people into
Caption: coding and I don't always know what has
Caption: the best hit rate like I'm a lot of
Caption: enthusiasm for it I don't know I always
Caption: know if it lands I found one of the most
Caption: engaging things you can do is introduce
Caption: a use for what they're building whether
Caption: that's something to do with a big global
Caption: cause or if it's just something that
Caption: they can use in their day to day life I
Caption: went out to
Caption: some kids near Rockingham and we just
Caption: showed them how to make like a basic
Caption: HTML page and I was worried they weren't
Caption: going to understand the concept but
Caption: within five minutes someone had made his
Caption: like top ten fortnight fax page so maybe
Caption: we could redirect some of that energy
Caption: towards some important global issues I
Caption: don't know but yeah all right to answer
Caption: your question if I knew how to make kids
Caption: do programming
Caption: I would I would tell you I tell everyone
Caption: but it's a bit of a mixed bag we have
Caption: time for a couple of more questions come
Caption: on ask me questions really actually good
Caption: to see that how beautiful it is and I
Caption: directly idea actually come out at from
Caption: the first talk is from the Web API you
Caption: can actually integrate with the speaker
Caption: and in my mind is like you can directly
Caption: do sound like music visualized musical
Caption: visualization and directly on the
Caption: website that potentially can help the
Caption: kids I think the combination of arts and
Caption: and computer science it just display is
Caption: such a beautiful and a simple way this
Caption: is not a question but just just so it's
Caption: just a direct feedback and and which is
Caption: one to give to you yes yeah thank you no
Caption: worries I think it is like making it
Caption: something that people can interact with
Caption: in different ways really grabs people's
Caption: attention so whether that's through
Caption: music or through them moving around in
Caption: front of something or putting a headset
Caption: on they find it very engaging so pretty
Caption: cool to me anyway honey
Caption: seems I'm just barging straight through
Caption: hi so you're pretty multidisciplinary
Caption: skilled I think but I'd say quite a lot
Caption: of people are quite specific in their
Caption: domains of knowledge and there's often a
Caption: difficulty in in connecting the arts
Caption: with engineering fields and scientific
Caption: fields do you have any thoughts on
Caption: avenues of approach which involve
Caption: connecting artists with programmers
Caption: rather than artists who are programmers
Caption: or programmers who are artists sort of
Caption: like ways to encourage collaboration and
Caption: stuff like that yeah one thing that I
Caption: try and do with my limited spare time is
Caption: a bit of mentoring in the community and
Caption: teaching people about programming and I
Caption: also have a lot of friends that they're
Caption: creators they really like they love to
Caption: make stuff and build things and I
Caption: definitely have a lot of plans in my
Caption: mind about like okay how can we teach
Caption: those creators how to use programming to
Caption: put some of those ideas into practice
Caption: practically I can't really run so many
Caption: workshops like but it's definitely I've
Caption: felt in in the Perth art community and
Caption: in the like Perth like performing arts
Caption: community and music communities like
Caption: there is a big when I talk about this
Caption: stuff people are so interested so I
Caption: think to answer your question is like I
Caption: need to run stuff and invite weirdo
Caption: creator types that I know and encourage
Caption: them to dip their toe in this hold field
Caption: I think it's a bit I I think it's not
Caption: quite a matter of like I don't want to
Caption: necessarily force computer programs to
Caption: be like oh you have to become more
Caption: artistic or more musical it's more that
Caption: I want to make programming seem more
Caption: approachable so people from lots of
Caption: different backgrounds can try it out and
Caption: do different things although you know if
Caption: people want to do art I'm like go for it
Caption: everyone should do oh it's really fun
Caption: thank you so much Alice please join me
Caption: for one last round of applause thank you
Caption: [Applause]